when you enter alibaba's headquarters in
Hangzhou China it's a lot like stepping
into any tech campus in Silicon Valley
inside there's a starbucks to fuel
all-nighters yoga classes and three
cafeterias serving employees dishes like
baking duck and lamb noodle soup but the
perks don't stop there Alibaba takes it
one step further helping employees by
love marriage and even start families it
may look like any other tech company but
the culture here is unique employees
refer to each other as all even or ollie
people and many assume nicknames taken
from kung fu novels one of the big
influences on jak masz life was an
author named genial who's a martial-arts
novelist so in the early days as they
were starting to bow people took on
nicknames of different characters that
were in these martial arts novels that
fighting spirit has attracted young
people to work at alibaba the average
employee is just 30 years old works 96
and has a starting salary of nearly
thirty three thousand dollars a year
that's more than seven times the average
urban Chinese orphan Alibaba attracts
young Chinese who are the top of their
fields because it's an exciting
corporate culture people feel that they
can break down barriers and do new cool
innovative types of things in their work
life Jack Ma is also unlike any tech
company founder
from serenading employees to play
matchmaker a heart-shaped dating board
between a gym and a cafeteria is filled
with photos and phone numbers of single
employees looking to find their match
right on campus Jack Ma himself is so
revered within the corporate culture
that every year ally day he actually
marries dozens if not hundreds of
alibaba employees and they actually now
have ali babies photos on the wall of
babies born to alibaba employees those
new ally families also can get an
interest-free loan for a down payment on
their first home and over the years
Alibaba has also given birth to a whole
new generation of Chinese Internet
companies former employees have helped
start more than a hundred and forty-five
new businesses they've attracted people
who believed they could do something
different individuals who are dreamers
and felt that they could change the
Chinese economy through Alibaba this
close-knit culture has been a critical
part of alibaba's identity and keeping
it all when the family has helped the
company grow into a global powerhouse
with over 24,000 employees that's more
than Facebook and Yahoo combined